all right turning now to big news on the
war in Ukraine where Ukrainian forces
have made sweeping gains in the
northeast of the country Ukrainian
troops have raised their flag in
multiple towns and Villages previously
occupied by Russian troops and take a
look at this map since early this month
the Ukrainian military says it has taken
back an area about the size of Rhode
Island Deborah patta has more from Kiev
Deborah good morning
good morning Ukraine's Battlefield
success in harkiva is one of the most
significant since they crushed Russia's
bid to seize the capital at the start of
this war they're counter-offensive has
already taken back just on the 2 000
square miles of lost territory
Ukrainian forces have swept through the
Northeast dead breathtaking speed
greeted like conquering Heroes
with flowers embracers and tears of joy
the blue ones yellow flag flying high in
liberated towns and Villages across the
region as advancing troops push North
just 30 miles from the Russian border
it's a humiliating defeat for Vladimir
Putin's men forced to flee abandoning
Key Supply hubs like kubiansk and isium
the Russians were here said dimitrienko
then suddenly they started shouting
wildly and running away charging off in
their tanks
for those who've lived under occupation
it's been over half a year of Hell
Tennessee I was scared all the time said
Mariah I can still see an image of a
huge puddle of blood in front of my eyes
and as the Russian troops ran fearing
they would be surrounded and captured
they left behind the usual trail of
Destruction devastation
and the possibility of fresh new crime
scenes for police to investigate
as they begin the now horribly familiar
task of digging up the bodies of
civilians killed by Russian soldiers
but as Moscow ordered its troops to
withdraw with the face-saving
explanation it was to reinforce the
Eastern Front Line
they fired off a gruesome Parting Gift a
missile strike on a thermal power plant
that left the area in a partial blackout
nobody believes this war will be over
quickly ukrainians have certainly been
emboldened by the steady supply of
Western military aid but say they need
more heavy weapons to keep this momentum
going Tony
Deborah pataforce in Ukraine where the
tide may be turning Deborah thank you
very much